Hi everyone.
Welcome to toxic Google.
We're very excited today
to welcome Alex Garland.
He is the director of the, depending on
when you see this upcoming film x Maki,
uh,
which was awesome and we screened it
yesterday and we were very excited to have
you here because technology and AI or
something that we're kind of interested in
just a little bit. Uh, I should probably
have said, well, welcome to blue book,
but a lot of people here, I
haven't seen it yet. Um, so let's,
let's talk a little bit about
first your background. Um,
you started mostly as a writer,
um,
and then producer and director of some
things as I'm a writer, you're a writer.
Um, so what was it about this subject
matter in this film that made you go,
this is the one I want to direct.
Oh, uh, uh, nothing.
All right.
Then
it was a,
I keep having this conversation
and I realize why, I guess,
and it's because we kind of dignify the
role of a director and it seems like a
really big deal. I've been working
for them for about 15 years.
A lot of it with the same group of people.
For me,
this is just part of a continuum.
It's just another film with the same
group of people largely. And, um,
there was no really significant difference
between this and the one before and
the one before that. And,
uh, it, it's because we,
the question stems from the fact that
we overstate the role of the director.
But that's what I would say.
But at the same time,
I think you,
depending on the relationship you have
with someone who's directing your own
material,
like you,
you have to have a lot of trust in
them to be true to whatever you're an
original intention was there. And that
that applies to the editor and you know,
the actors as well. But, but by
being both the writer and director,
you do have an extra
sort of level of control.
Yeah.
But now you've shifted the presupposing
onto the other directors and assuming I
gave them that level of control, if
you see what I mean. And the, uh,
uh, and really what it is, the key
thing you said is that the editor,
the dop, the actors film
is, is broadly a color.
It is a collaborative process.
Having come from books,
which is not a collaborative process for
the most part, uh, I can stay film is,
I think it would be fair to say, and, and,
and all of the people in that film have
a real insignificant role and it's not
just paying lip service to
it. They really, really do.
That's why production companies fight
like crazy over who the dop is or who the
production designer is.
If it was just observing the sort of,
the vision of the director,
what difference, you know.
Fair enough. Right. Um, okay.
Well then what were some of your
influences for this particular story? Uh,
sort of cinema about cinematically
and maybe I'm visually, uh, you know,
the history of artificial intelligence
in cinema has definitely been something
that's been portrayed in
many different ways. Yes. Um,
so what were some of the
things that you drew from
well, uh, uh,
or that may not look it from the stories
I've sort of Zombie movies and stuff
I've worked on previously.
I tried to draw as much from real
life observation as possible. Um,
I had got involved with a long running
argument, a good natured argument,
but still an argument with
a neuroscientist friend of
mine who comes from that
very respectable position that exists
within a theory of mind about humans,
but also AI research,
which basically says machines
and ever going to be conscious.
There's something particular about
human consciousness that hasn't been
understood yet.
And when we do understand it,
we will see why machines are
precluded from ever being sent in.
And um, uh, I think on an instinctive
level, I disagreed with him and then we,
we sort of argued over years and mainly
this film comes out of that argument.
Uh,
I finally came across a book written by
the professor of cognitive robotics at
imperial,
which is like our version of Mit.
And it was about the relationship
between consciousness and embodiment.
And he has a really sort of beautiful,
elegant argument in it, which,
which combats I think quite effectively.
Some of the arguments I would hear.
And so,
uh,
and while I was reading that book and I
have to stress very hard for me to read
that book and I could
only read sections of it,
it's like mountain climbing for me. But,
um, uh, while I was reading that book,
the idea for this film kind of arrived.
Um, so you, you definitely delve into
some of the, the headier ish, you know,
issues of what is, what is humanity,
but his personality, what is, you know,
what is it, uh, Centene creature.
And so what were sort of
some of the challenges of,
of getting this heady topic material of
like subject matter and it has a lot of
scientific implications to translate to
a cinematic story as well as something
that is also a human story.
And like not getting too bogged down in
the science but still convey it was a
challenge. You picked a big challenge,
right? Your subject matter. Um,
um, yeah, it was a, yeah,
the guest there was a challenge
involved. Um, I was just trying to be,
I was trying to be fair to
the subject matter I guess,
and tried to be respectful about it and
really try to understand it within my
own limitations as best as I
could before writing it. Um, uh,
partly because I think it's
interesting and uh, um, it,
it's an area where this is true of lots
of area of science at the moment where
there's a,
there's a kind of increasing vacuum
between the people who are actually doing
this stuff and the, and the rest of
us who were trying to understand it.
And so some of it's about trying to
bridge that vacuum as best as possible,
but it's, it's really tough to do
that. Um, the thing about it is,
is that any look strong AI also becomes
a look at human consciousness that the
two are related.
The problems of one a kind of the
problems of the other to an extent. Um,
only to an extent. I don't personally
think that when a strong AI arrives,
it will necessarily be like us.
In many ways.
It may be completely different
from in almost always, but,
but the issues and the conversations in
this current state of not understanding
are very related. So, uh, yeah.
Okay. Um, let's,
let's talk about the more
human factors in your,
you've had a really wonderful cast.
Um, I thought that, uh, Alicia,
you see it. Yes. Uh,
she brought just this really great quality
of sort of inhuman but human to the
character of Ava and I'm sure that's
exactly what you wanted to had, uh,
wanted her to bring to it. Were there
things that you worked on to kind of, uh,
get her to telegraph that
sort of human but not
she, she arrived with it?
Um, um, I mean we had,
I'd seen her in other movies and we
had various conversations and stuff,
but when she arrived, she had this site
there. She's a ballerina by training,
so she has a terrific control over her
physicality as well as being a very,
very good at. She was very
grateful. She was very gracious,
almost unsettling in a character
way, but, well exactly.
So do you know the VF that you know,
the Vfx team,
cause you used to work in
Vfx uncanny valley. Yes.
So what she did was a kind of uncanny
valley version of human motion.
She said, I'm not, I'm not
going to act like a robot,
what I'm going to do as human actions,
but I'm going to do them perfectly.
And that perfection will
create a sense of otherness.
Cause like when I'm sat on this chair
actually your rather sort of graceful by
not and I sort of slouch and uh, if
I get up I have to sort of, you know,
shove myself up and come back my middle
age and all that kind of stuff. And so,
uh, whereas she does it with
this amazing sort of dance,
has poise and it's hard to look at it and
say anything she does is sort of quote
unquote wrong, but together it
creates this uncanny valley,
slightly unnatural quality.
Yes. Uh, so you wrap
the end, came to valley.
And I thought I was almost afraid
seeing the trailers that, you know,
all the footage was, it was
beautiful. And I was like, okay,
I don't think they're going to hit it.
And you didn't, you didn't fall into that,
which was amazing. But it's a
challenge, especially considering the,
the anatomy of the main character for
the majority of the film. You know,
we see her in this kind of robotic hybrid
synthetic like with a human face and
it's a little unsettling. And at times
she's just so perfect looking that,
you know,
but there's the,
you've managed to still capture like
a human ish elements so it didn't hit,
you know, the, the too cartoonish
and to humanoid. Um, it,
yeah, that'll be great.
Congratulations on that.
Thank sort of, I mean, the, um,
the funny thing is
about people is that we,
we are urges to project human like
qualities and to almost everything,
it, it's, it's almost an effort to
stop it happening. Um, I mean there is,
there's incredibly beautiful VFX and
there's beautiful production design and
it's beautifully shot and it's beautifully
lit and all those kinds of things.
But, uh, um,
that thing of making this strange machine
believing that it has the qualities
that we have, that's actually
really quite easy. I,
the that is to say you could take
it with a child who, you know,
it's probably quite hard to
find children that don't, uh,
attribute sentience to they're cuddly
toys. Right. In, in some ways. And,
and that's where I guess it begins when
in fact it probably begins because it's
sort of semi coded into
us in some respects. Um,
I was driving not that long ago with
an adult who is feeling pissed off with
their car and kind of critical event and,
um,
but didn't want to say so in front of the
car in case it hurt the cause feelings
right. Now that that's a
grownup. Right. Um, and, uh, so,
um, uh, and cause don't look much like
us pretty, you know, more or less.
Um, so, uh, so yeah. Um, I mean, I
know you're being kind about the films,
I'm not trying to be combative.
It's your film is, it's a
collective, right? Yeah, sure. I,
I, you know, I think there are a
lot of, of times when, you know,
we see these sort of representation
of humanity but not humanity and,
and you really want to project onto it.
And what you had to do is kind of
combat that a little bit. You like
a lot of the plot of it kind of hinges
on us accepting this artificial element
to it. True. Um,
true. So, so initially what you do
is in a very kind of upfront way,
you say this is a machine and there's
no ambiguity. It's a machine, right?
And there's all sorts of things
to force you to think that way.
There's cavities where they shouldn't be
cavities and you can see through her in
a way that, uh, sort of removes her
being like us, a girl in a suit,
you know? And then the,
the, the task of the film,
Mr Gradually have that machine
quality fall away. Right?
Even though she looks kind of the same.
And,
and to show just by behavior,
we will,
we will forget the thing
that's right in front of us.
Yup. Um, so the, the VFX team behind this
did an amazing job, you know, it was,
it was fantastic and a shout out to them.
Uh,
can you talk about working with them,
especially having basically one of your
protagonist characters be mostly CG for
a good portion of the movie?
Yeah. Um, uh, well they were run
it, it's a company called DNA, uh,
or double negative, which, uh,
based in London where I live and work
and our team was run by a guy called
Andrew Whitehurst. And, um,
in the course of my life,
every now and then I've met some really,
really smart people and I think he may be
the smartest guy I've ever met. I mean,
he may or may not. It's, uh, but, but he's
certainly going to be in the top tier. Um,
the,
the thing about him that is so interesting
is he's got a real gift for sort of
poetry in a way, you know, that
beauty and things like that.
So I remember one day he said, look,
I've got this great idea, which is to uh,
hang plastic strips inside her form,
which will diffuse the
light in a particular kind
of way and make us slightly
more mysterious even though you can
see the machinery. And so that's,
that's a lovely kind of poetic idea.
And then another day we ran into
this massive quality control issue.
It's kind of technical and I
will fail to explain it properly,
but basically we were getting, because of
the way the images on the Sony cameras,
we'd use it being sort of
processed or something. I Dunno,
we were getting these weird straight
pixels and I'm in big flat areas of color.
Suddenly there'd be these straight pixels.
And we had a problem because we were going
to fail a quality control thing to do
with the distributor when we handed the
film over and he said, ah, don't worry,
I'll fix that.
And he wrote some piece of code over
like a week and it reprocessed all of the
imagery and it fixed it and made
it go away. So I'm thinking,
I don't know how to talk to this guy now.
He's just like such got a range of
abilities. It's just unreal. So thanks.
That's impressive. Um, what, what, uh,
what sort of mixture of it was working
with that team and working with the
actors in terms of,
you know,
integrating this character because
if it had gone wrong, the movie,
we would have been lost as an audience.
You know,
you would've been in snap out of it and
it would have probably hit that weird
uncanny valley in the wrong
way. In the wrong way. Yeah.
Yes. So, uh, yeah, I mean, my,
my approach to filmmaking in my approach
very much played out in this film is
about, uh, this is gonna sound
like corporate speak, right?
But it's about these different departments
having a lot of communication between
each other and also a lot of autonomy.
Um,
and that would include the actors and
it would clean the VFX team and the
composers and, and so on. So it's
not, it's not separate group. It's,
it's sort of roughly like
what you'd imagine anarchy
would be like ideally where
you have autonomous groups not
kind of chucking bricks but uh,
but kind of agreeing about a common goal.
I think that's the key is agreeing
about a common goal and then,
and then having a lot of independence
and autonomy within it. And uh, um,
uh, any department you could mention
that would have been the approach.
Hmm.
Well,
so speaking of the subject matter that
I'm working with technical technically
challenging things,
a lot of your sort of subject
matter is this sort of futuristic,
but I want to do like a little bit
apocalyptic in terms of like 28 days later
and sunshine was the, like if we have
to restart that sun and apocalypse,
uh, uh, they're, they're sort
of very challenging things
that, uh, to accomplish.
I think visually,
you know,
you need to have a lot of trust in the
teams that are taking these to task.
Um, has that ever like the
challenge of it ever influenced you?
Have you ever thought, oh,
maybe I want to do this?
Or you just go with the creative process
and just trust the trust your teams to
make it work.
Well, you've got to aim
high. Right. And, uh,
and I think one of the things
is that broadly speaking,
if people feel like they're aiming high
and they're having to work slightly
outside of their comfort zone, they
raise their game. And, uh, that,
that's just kind what
happens. And, uh, um, it, the,
the key is the vibe in
a way. You know, it's,
it's like the atmosphere of it
where, um, uh, it, it's not,
it's very easy with collaboration
to have it work with lip service.
You sort of say, yeah, yeah,
we're collaborative and just would
you mind doing it this way? You know,
and then we'll be really collaborative
slightly later and so on. Um,
but I think if you in almost in four set,
uh,
provided you've got the right people
at works great. I have to say,
I've worked on films where it's been just
the most miserable experience and it's
been completely horrified. It is. It is
down to the people you're working with.
The collaboration can turn into mush
really easily if you're working with a no,
I'm going to stop
talking, but um, but yeah.
Well tell me you want to be in the
trenches with, you know, it's, it's, yeah,
when it comes down to the can feel
like editing and stuff like that,
like who is going to be a positive
influence on the creativity as opposed to
just doing decent typically. Yeah.
Is the main thing. It's okay.
It's a good metric. Um, what,
what are some of the experiences that
you've had previously that you brought to
this filmmaking experience that
you thought really, you know, I,
it sounds like you've worked
for some of the team before.
Like what were some of the
things that you thought,
I really need to bring this to the table,
uh, when approaching this, this film?
Well actually a lot of it,
I don't know if it it in a way it's
of interest to anyone by I'd worked in
science fiction that would have been
stemmed originally from some kind of
science conceit by entropy, heat
death or something like that. And um,
uh, and, and had sacrificed
at a certain point, uh,
anything resembling rationality for
story concerns about adrenaline or,
or,
you know,
perceived story concerns about a
journaling and what would I really felt.
My main goal with this form was,
uh,
I may never get to do this
again for all sorts of reasons.
I may never get to do this again.
So I'm just going to try as in my sphere
in this table with many legs to just do
it right,
to do it as right as I can.
Not compromise on anything at all
by literally nothing in my sphere.
And, um, uh, so I guess
that was the main thing.
Film has terrific
influences to compromise,
built into the fabric of how they get
made and how they get distributed in
finance and all sorts of things.
And in this instance,
it was to step away from that.
That's it's having, it's great
that you were able to do that. Uh,
I think that's something that
a lot of directors strive for.
And then when it comes down to
then making the decision, they,
they end up having to compromise through
whatever set of circumstances they
might be the guys requiring
the compromise. But that
that's also very possible.
Um, what, uh,
actually speaking of the
collaboration element of it, um,
can you talk about working with rob hardy
or cinematographer because if even the
film was very like beautifully
shot. Yeah. Um, and I think it,
it just all sort of tied visually
together with this beautiful artificial
creature and, and then this
beautiful setting. And um, yeah.
How did you work with him to
rubs just an artist? He did. It's very
important. It's, it's quite interesting.
You can put any camera in his hands and
he will just find a way to frame the
thing. And, um, uh, it, if you,
it's like not knowing how to play guitar,
I guess it's kind of,
if you don't know how he's doing it,
but you can see how good he is.
It's truly mysterious. There's something
really, uh, kind of weird about it.
Um, he's, he's just a very,
very talented dop and, uh,
uh, he's, he's known in the scene, I
guess for being very good anyway. And,
um, uh, he, he, he and I, uh,
been close to working
together before on a movie,
never let me go with about
four years ago. And he was, uh,
one of the dops in the
frame for that film,
but it didn't work out for
various reasons. Um, but he was,
he was just like the perfect choice for
this because he's kind of sense your and
warm and,
uh,
Scifi can be quite antiseptic and
clinical. It sort of goes to the,
the hospital and you know,
Saifai and his instinct is about almost
like dropping a gauze over everything
and being soft and zen like,
and so I, he was perfect for it.
Yeah,
I think,
I think zen is a great adjective to
describe the second setting of the film.
You know,
it's this beautiful retreat and woods
and waterfalls and rivers and it's like,
it's somewhere I'd want to
vacation. Yeah. It's available.
Rent gets it now.
Um,
it might have an extra guest in it still.
It's a hotel. Oh, we showed it
and I tell in Norway, um, uh,
it's a really core eco hotel and um,
the landscape is absolutely stunning. I,
one of the funny things about film is
that it both loves and hates familiarity,
you know, and uh, finding a landscape
that has not been well used in film,
it's quite difficult.
I've noticed there's been like tons
of movies recently that I've used.
Icelanders are location.
Yeah.
And once you get sort of zoned into
that Iceland Vibe, you think, oh,
we're back here again even, or are you
thinking consciously or unconsciously?
Actually and um, uh, Norway
had something special about it.
There's a kind of bleakness in it.
It's beautiful and very majestic,
stunning skies and mountains
and waterfalls, as you said.
But there's something a bit kind
of hard to bed kind of bleak.
Um, was it, I'm going to assume it
was at a point to justice position,
kind of the nature of
factor with the natural
elements, maybe not a natural
next evolution elements of
highly,
highly contained,
controlled environment created by a man,
a completely uncontrolled
environment created by no one,
those two arguably.
And uh, um, I taught this in detail.
Uh,
speaking of the kind of control element,
everything did feel very even plot wise
and, and behavior wise of the characters.
Everything felt very planned in a,
in a good way in a keeping the
audience on their toes and like what,
who is in charge of what, who's making
the decisions, who is, you know,
who's playing, who was the puppet
master, kind of a in a lot of ways.
And was it tough to kind of keep the,
the audience's trust for some of
that and say like, no, go with me.
Like you'll figure out who and,
or,
or did you want to kind of keep people
a little disoriented the whole time?
Um,
what are the,
the thing that,
there's a funny thing about film,
which is that you can assume
literacy on the part of the viewer.
It's not necessarily true in books.
You could write a book which
alludes to heart of darkness,
but you would not be able to assume
they'd read Conrad and read heart of
darkness. Whereas with a film viewer,
you can pretty much assume, for example,
they've seen blade runner, right? Uh,
and in fact you might even be able to
assume they've seen apocalypse now,
which is based on hard in some respects.
But so,
so that is this funny thing about the
wave film works and what it, it's,
it's kind of a free gift in terms of
what you were talking about in terms of
that relationship with the
audience because some of
these things have been well
established and then you can
use them to your advantage.
So in the case of this film,
a smart literate film
viewer is very quickly,
almost immediately you're going to be
thinking she's not the robot. He is.
It's just going to be an automatic
assumption. They're just going to do it.
And then what you can do is
use misdirection and nudge
them a little bit further
towards that because he's got oddly
symmetrical scars on his back,
which has for justification within
the narrative about a car crash.
But you're thinking, yeah, that's not
why. And, and the, uh, and so, you know,
so you use that stuff to your advantage.
It's, it's, uh, it's very useful.
But the basic function of this film is to,
is,
is it's intending to set
up a series of questions.
Some of the questions it's setting
up it like where does gender reside,
for example, it doesn't then
necessarily have an answer to it.
And in fact,
it might be saying it is impossible to
present a clear answer to some of these
questions about consciousness or gender
or AI or whatever it happens to be at
this moment in time.
We're not able to do that.
But that doesn't negate the reason to ask
the question and have the conversation.
And it's basically an idea's movie.
It's, it's to provoke conversation and,
and to hopefully do it in a sort
of respectful and thoughtful way.
What would be the intention?
Yeah,
I think, I think it absolutely
accomplished that. And you know,
you mentioned the scars on the back
and that was one of the things that
immediately after the movie was
talking about, it's like, wow,
I wonder if that was part
of something else or do you,
are we meant to thank you so robot
and, um, but it, you know, it's,
it's exactly where you want the audience
to go with it, which is misdirection.
Right? But it's still,
it, it helped it frame.
I'd try to talk about without spoiling
anything, you know, it helped,
it helped frame later
events in the film, uh, and,
and create this sort of
tension until the end, which,
and I won't say exactly
what happens in the end,
but the ending was just fantastic and
thank you for, thank you for kind of not,
not giving us what we expected.
I think it kept true to the sort of the,
the, the feeling and plot you'd set
up prior to the very ending. And, uh,
I think if you'd gone with
this sort of cliche route, uh,
we might have been a little disappointed.
Yeah, it wouldn't, no, it would have been,
it still would have been satisfying.
But I think the,
the sort of way that I can I just say it.
You say what you like,
I'm going to spoiler alert warning
here. Um, so, uh, no, at the end.
Oh yeah, sorry. Um, but if, if you
know, the, the way that the robot,
sorry, maybe I won't, he's shaking his
head. Oh nevermind. I was, spoiler alert.
It's great. Go see it. I'm
okay. Either way. The ending
is fantastic. Thank you. Um,
and it's unexpected and I think it really
does like service to your audience and
trusting them and saying like,
here are all the points and I trusted
you to come up with this unable reward
that with keeping true to the characters.
Thank you.
I'm sorry for almost point linkage.
Um, let's see what else. Uh, I want
to talk to a little more about,
about the actors, sort of what was the
process? Cause it's a very limited cast.
Yeah.
Um,
Donald Gleason was a great and sort of
charming in this almost innocent way.
Um,
I'd worked with him twice before. So, uh,
I knew donor would be really
good for this and, uh,
actually just simply called him
up one day and said, hey, look,
I'm going to send you a
script. What he'd do it. Uh,
I mean obviously if he didn't want to do
it, I can make it. Uh, so, so yeah. Uh,
try as I might. So, so that, that was
donut. And then with the other two, um,
uh, the thing about actors is, and I
really think this is a fair statement,
is that there's no mystery to good
actors. When you see it, you just know it.
When you see it. It, it's, it's
hard to find somebody who would say,
Phillip Seymour Hoffman was a bad actor.
He was sort of evident in the,
an incredibly good actor.
That tends to be the case with good ones.
You don't need to be an expert.
This film required the
costing of good actors, uh,
that there is a kind of actor who
isn't necessarily a good actor,
but they have an enormous
amount of charisma.
And that can be fantastic
for certain kinds of films.
Charisma is just what you want to make it
function. Uh, but this particular film,
they needed to be act as a of
a certain type really. And, um,
so,
so that was,
that was the pool we were
drawing from Oscar Isaac. Uh,
I'd seen them in lots of
stuff actually. Uh, and um,
he's one of those guys who within the
industry is incredibly buzzy and uh,
and very,
very well respected and Elisia for candor.
I'd seen her in a Danish movie
called a royal affair. Um, right.
I'm going to guess she was in her early
twenties or maybe even late teens when
she shot that she's acting opposite
mads Mikkelsen who's a fantastically
experience charismatic and
terrific actor as well.
And despite that, you, your eye just goes,
she's got that magnetic ability that
some people have. And uh, so she was,
she was perfect that that was
essentially the, the roots I suppose.
I think she did such a lovely
job move. Yeah. She's, she's
shouldering this interesting kind of
dead lucky with that cost.
And, and going back to Oscar, Isaac,
um, you know, thinking, Oh yes,
that the dancing was just so
unexpected and phenomenal. Um,
but he, uh, he had his sort of
charisma of his own and you know,
not necessarily the sort of big
boisterous Hollywood personality charisma,
but the character itself had a very
interesting kind of draws you in,
makes you want to, you know,
find out what he's doing.
And I think that was sort of
integral to the plot of it, you know,
is having this guy who makes you
want to find out more. Um, yeah.
Is that part of the reason you cast him
or is that something you saw in him or
is that something that kind of
came out later in the process?
No, no, no. I mean that, that was the
intention of the story. I mean he, he's a,
it's a tricky thing because he's the CEO
of a big Tech Company and immediately
that leads people to think
he's kind of aimed at somebody.
But it wasn't really that at all.
I mean,
in a way I was thinking more
about people like Oppenheimer.
There's lots of red because AI as we know,
because we're informed by Stephen Hawkins
and Elon Musk and people like that is,
has, has latent potential for
being extremely dangerous. And, uh,
and I think that has to be true.
It is, it is potentially dangerous.
But I also think it's reasonably
analogist with nuclear power,
which is also dangerous, but it doesn't
stop us using it. And, um, uh, and,
and I'm basically in favor of Ai.
I think it's terrific and I'm fascinated
by it and sort of all power to it. What,
maybe not all but a
lot of power to it. Um,
and, uh, so, so the thing with,
with Oscar's character was to be a kind
of Oppenheimer like character who's
conflicted about what he's
doing as he's doing it. And,
and it's up to the audience in a sense to,
to understand where he's really coming
from because he presents himself as being,
uh, incredibly kind of misogynistic and
predatory and then actually violent.
And then you have to decide,
is this an act he's putting on for
the purposes of this experiment?
Or is it real?
Or is it something in himself that he's
helplessly amplifying for the experiment?
Like w there's all sorts of,
uh,
things that it could be an Oscars are
very kind of liquid actor and that kind of
set of challenges of where you, where
are you at this moment in a scene is,
is exactly what kind of turns him on
really and get some going. So yeah,
I think it's,
it's also a testament to the writing of
the character and the portrayal by the
actor.
But it was,
it was one of the more sort of complex
characters that I didn't know if how you
want it to like, you know, identify with
him or support him or just be like, oh,
you're horrible.
Well, you were invited. Clearly
to think that is horrible.
There are several stages
of the film where it,
where it is almost
instructing the viewer to say,
feel deeply suspicious and uncomfortable
with this guy. Um, however,
there's another thing as well,
or at least I hope there is,
which is that sometimes
the things he's saying,
even though he sounds like he's
wrong or actually true. Um,
and so it,
it's the ability to hear past what's
something sounds like it is to actually
what it is, right. It was
vehicle that's delivering it as opposed
to the actual message. Um, yeah,
he's an interesting vehicle to deliver
it. We'll try it. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
so yeah, you say you're in favor of
artificial intelligence and to a degree,
yeah. Which I mean, like strong.
I mean these AI sort of conflate
so many different things.
This AI and phones and video
games and I mean, do you know,
we're talking about strong
AI, right? To use that term,
generally.
What, what was it like working with
the science advisors on this? Um,
just because I didn't know,
you mentioned this conversation with your
ongoing discussion that led to a movie
with that and your neuroscience
scientists. Right. And, and I'm, I'm,
I'm going to go ahead and guess that
there were a lot of science advisors
involved because the,
there were three particular in advisors.
There was a lady called GM, Milena vetch,
and there was a geneticist to also
fronts, uh, uh, a radio show actually,
which is sort of trying to disseminate
scientific discussion on radio four BBC
thing, uh, called Adam Rutherford. But
there was this guy, Murray Shanahan, and,
uh, he was, um, he works
at imperial and, uh,
he was the guy, all of these
people, what I said is, look, I,
I've attempted to write this thing as
best as I can understand it from the
literature and from a youtube videos
of lectures and stuff like this.
Check it, be really, really
tough on it. If it seems wrong,
if this is an inaccurate representation
of Mary and the black and white room or
whatever it happens to be as a thought
experiment or whatever, tell me now,
obviously it's got two big conceits in it.
There's,
there's a robot that has a level of
robotics that clearly doesn't exist yet.
Uh, yeah, sure. Yeah. But, but doesn't,
and there's also a machine that
really does seem to be sent to you,
and that also doesn't exist.
Um, uh, I, I'm probably yet, um,
so,
uh,
so there's a limit to how much you can
advise on something which is fiction,
right. But, but to be reasonable about
the subject was the key thing I think.
Um, and have, have you sort of applied
the same thing to your, your password?
Because I mean they've,
no, no, I haven't. I haven't and that's
why I did it with this because, uh,
I felt like I had let down the
subject matter previously. And,
um,
so when I'm talking about earlier,
when we were chatting
about not compromising,
that's basically what I'm
talking about. Um, uh,
I feel frustrated with some of that stuff.
So yeah,
I think it puts you in a sort of position
where you, you might be given, you know,
if he'd come back and say Xyz doesn't
work because of this, you know,
puts you in a tough position where you
might have to compromise on your own work.
So,
no, because then I wouldn't have done
it, but, but the, but the key was a,
you make it cheaply that if you want
creative freedom, make it for less money.
Oh, I, I meant plot wise and stuff
like that. Okay. All right. All right.
Nevermind that in any terms
you can think of, the less money you
make it for them, more freedom you got.
Yeah. Um, so what, uh, what are
some of your, you know, what,
what other subjects would you like
to delve into going forward? Um, um,
what are some of the other
things that interest,
well,
I'm trying to,
I've just finished the script a have
a really fascinating novel called
annihilation written by a guy called
Jeff and Amir Mirror. And I'm going to,
I'm trying, I've tried to adapt
that and I'm going to wait.
I'm in the process now what I'm out here
in the states of trying to set that up
and hopefully we'll
succeed. And, um, uh, um,
I came across this very
interesting argument that
talked about how well the all
life on the planet is cellular and um,
and it has,
there's an argument which is,
has actually some evidence attached
to it incredibly, which is the,
all of those cells are
derived from one cell,
which actually makes logical sense
when you start to think about it.
But I never had stopped
to think about it and um,
that is a truly extraordinary idea.
That's one of the reasons I liked science
and I liked science fiction is because
I think it puts these really
fundamental, fascinating, uh,
sort of ideas into your head. And so, um,
I guess that's what I'm
fixated on at the moment.
That's a very interesting subject to you.
You kind of approach the starch
macro things that make us,
I feel like examine when she like it
is to be human almost, isn't it? Yeah.
It makes you think
good about the future in the
past and where you are in it.
But there's,
I guess there's an approach to it also
that is a sort of looking at it from the
human standpoint on it as opposed to
like just a purely scientific because
there's a way to tell those stories
and explain like, you know, like,
oh well we became from one
cell as opposed to being like,
think about the ramifications
of this. Um, and,
and exploring that as opposed to just
how to presenting scientific evidence.
Yeah. Um, well, uh, I'll ask what's, um,
what's one piece of advice that you
wish you could've given yourself before
going into this project? What, this one?
Yes. And then going to your next one. No,
nothing.
It was all cool.
It was great.
It was a good bunch of people and it
worked out in the way it was supposed to.
I've never been able to say that before,
but I can say about this.
What's that?
What's one thing in particular that you
draw from this experience that you'd
like to bring into the next one?
Is it the not compromising is with
most people work with nice people.
I think that's a great thing.
Um,
I think we cool. We cool. Thank
you so much for joining us. Uh,
eczema keynote will be out in
theaters. Uh, got it. Thanks so much.
Okay.